in the darkest of times they came to
light candles the shock on young faces
friends left in disbelief that two of
their fellow students are among the Dead
between the flowers a cricket cap left
at a vigil to remember the lives so
suddenly cut short
literally hundreds of of people poured
in and out of this church here in the
center of a city that's been filled with
grief and shock today and and you could
sense that palpably here many young
people many students who who came here
to to
just to be in it and do something today
when when they've they've kind of felt
an overwhelming sense of of loss
students are living just yards from
where their friends were stabbed the
road where they were attacked is a
well-trodden route back after nights out
in the city center the fear among
students is it could have been anyone I
was going to go home on Saturday but I'm
just I just picked my train ticket I'm
gonna go tomorrow like I know it's not
like a normal thing that happens here
but it's still a bit stressful so I'm
just gonna just go home this young
vibrant part of the city has felt eerily
quiet as police cordons block off
streets that should have been full of
students out enjoying the Sun at the end
of term
with large parts of the city affected
the atmosphere here has been tense the
main question is why anyone would do
this
across Nottingham police continue their
work to find answers for the victims and
their loved ones
thoughts and prayers are just with their
families as as a parent you just can't
imagine that
phone call from the police to them to
tell them that they're as we now know
young people students
19 years old are not coming home again
it is that horror that's haunting this
city but people here are determined to
join together to try to find strength in
each other Becky Johnson Sky News
Nottingham